Well,
I mean,
I think,
um,
maybe,
maybe it'll just be,
you can only have an electric car,
um,
you know,
maybe 10 years from now,
like it'll be illegal in the u s to build,
uh,
like,
you know,
a gas guzzling car.
I got an alert to car recently and it's amazing the blowback from my friends.
What are they sensing?
Well,
first of all,
it's always homophobic or,
or a or a feminine.
They're always going after you about your estrogen levels and your manhood.
It's like,
it's weird.
It's kind of like a space.
I mean,
Tesla's are kind of like,
there's kind of like space ships though.
They feel,
I mean,
there's only been in one.
Yeah,
he driven one.
I haven't driven one.
I've driven in one.
I've,
I drove in one years ago and I wasn't that impressed,
I want to say like maybe five or six years ago,
but now I have one of the new ones that's crazy fast.
It doesn't even make sense.
Regular cars are stupid.
They're stupid.
And you spend all that money on gas.
Why would you want to do that?
But I mean,
they're stupid.
Like they don't work as good.
Like that thing is way better than any car I've ever driven and it's only gonna
get better there.
They don't even make sense how fast they are and they drive themselves.
Yeah.
Like you hit this little thing.
Go do do and it just fucking steers.
It takes over.
Yeah,
like it drives,
yeah.
And it's,
it stays within the speed limit and you can just kind of half ass space out
because keep your hand on the steering wheel and it a,
it breaks when there's cars in front of you and slow.
It's very strange.
I'll even change lanes for you.
Amazing.
It's fucked.
It's weird.
It's,
it's very difficult to let go and to give in like that.
But the strange thing that I felt was the,
the blowback from my friends like,
and they're joking around.
Obviously most of my friends are comedians,
but it's a,
it's hilarious.
Even people have heckled me about,
yeah.
Well,
I feel that like I just at the aesthetic level,
I understand that mocking of like the Prius,
but I feel like the Tesla is actually,
it looks a macho,
well the piece is a piece of shit.
It's like a cheese wedge wheels.
But I mean it's like,
you know,
yeah,
we live in a sick culture where like being like healthy and responsible.
It's like I'll just take staff.
It was like cigarettes and whiskey in mock,
someone eating a salad.
It's very weird.
It is very weird.
But um,
I was a,
that is an American problem.
Like other parts in the world,
they don't,
they're not as attached to their trucks and shit.
Grouse were gross,
but,
but there's something particularly strange about being on that side of it.
Cause I was um,
I wanna,
I don't want to say I was pessimistic about electric cars,
but when Elan did the podcast,
I told him I'd buy one of his cars because he was,
he was telling me how great they are.
I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm probably one of your cars.
But I really did not expect to like it as much as I do.
And then once I got it,
I was like,
oh,
okay,
now I get it.
Yeah.
But then I was thinking about my own resistance to it because I like cars.
I have,
you know,
muscle cars.
I have a couple,
I have an older Porsche.
I love them.
They're fun.
I liked those kinds of cars,
but they're stupid.
They really are dumb.
That's a dumb way to get around the Tesla is a way better way to get around.
Yeah.
And you know,
he's got one that's coming out in 2020 that's going to have a 660 mile range,
which is insane.
I mean,
you drive all the way to San Francisco and back with one charge,
you know?
I mean,
he's incredible.
I think,
you know,
I like there,
there are reasons why he gets the shit that he gets.
But I also think like Tesla and solar city are incredibly important.
And I'm actually,
I don't understand why there aren't more people in Silicon Valley who are
focused on climate in this way.